unicorn rainbow farts and the return of
cornholio space sucks but beavis and
butthead do the universe rules
like beavis and butthead do america the
new film starts out very strong with an
awesome action-packed intro while their
first film opened up to a pastiche of
kaiju films featuring a giant beavis and
butthead stomping through a city and
spewing fire from their mouths due the
universe opens with a cool star wars
inspired space chase beavis and butthead
are briefly rendered in full cgi
piloting a small spacecraft in what
looks like a replica of the death star
trench being chased by enemy ships
shooting green lasers at them it's a
great well-directed action sequence
plopping beavis and butthead into a
scene from a high-stakes space opera to
say things like
that was cool then they blow up right
before the opening title because they
were looking at all the cool explosions
instead of what was right in front of
them seems fitting
while it is obviously improbable that
two dumb teens especially ones as
comically dumb as beavis and butthead
would ever ever get a chance to board a
nasa rocket ship writers mike judge and
lou morton came up with a relatively
clever reason as to how that would be
possible in beavis and butthead to the
universe after beavis and butthead
create a science fair mishap that leads
to their school burning down the two
were given a court order to attend a
nasa space camp which was slated to be
the prize for the fair's winner this is
because the fire beavis and butt had
created has destroyed the records of the
real winner and the judge assigned to
their case recently watched an episode
of touched by an angel inspiring him to
give the at-risk boys a second chance
once at the camp beavis and butthead are
obviously bored by all the science stuff
except for a docking machine that mimics
sexual intercourse so they spend all day
and all night practicing the docking
maneuver to the point that they become
experts the nasa astronauts
unfortunately mistake their enthusiasm
for the machine as them being
technological prodigies rather than
horny boys who just see sex everywhere
the person who is initially the most
gung-ho about beavis and butthead
joining the space mission due to their
surprising aptitude for the docking
machine is captain serena ryan this
assertive astronaut keeps
misunderstanding beavis and butthead's
clear and unhealthy sexual attraction to
her as enthusiasm for the space mission
this is exemplified in one of their
first meetings where she tells the boys
i want you to do that for real in space
with me she means operating the docking
controls in actual space rather than
what they obviously think she means
however one of the funniest exchanges
happens when they're all fully dressed
in their spacesuits marching towards the
launching rocket this whole time beavis
and butthead have assumed they've been
training to sleep with ryan you know how
few people have done what you're about
to do obviously she means going to space
but the misunderstanding only gets worse
from there only 256 men
and 49 women
that's a little more than i was hoping
but you know that's okay she then goes
on to add that's not even counting the
russian dog and the monkey enough beavis
and butthead as a series and a concept
always thrived on contrast while it may
seem to many viewers that the
superficial appeal of beavis and
butthead is their gross out humor and
slapstick shenanigans the truth is that
only works when they're in opposition to
something more intellectual so their
stupidity is usually best served like a
lot of the best buffoonish comedy when
going against a straight man or in this
case a straight woman this worked great
in the show such as when their
idealistic hippie homeroom teacher mr
van driessen tried to get through to the
boys using art or other outlets and it
was always hilarious seeing his efforts
getting completely dashed by
overestimating beavis and butthead's
abilities and underestimating their lack
of self-awareness the same goes for
captain serena ryan who while in the
nasa shuttle takes beavis and butthead
to the ship's cockpit to show them the
sun rising over the earth from space her
speech wonderfully delivered by actress
andrea savage is backed by a rousing and
inspirational musical score all of this
makes butthead's quick declaration when
she leaves all the more hilarious the
earth
[Music]
sucks one of the ongoing jokes among
fans of beavis and butthead is how
visually distinct they are even when
compared to other characters on the show
everyone else in their universe seems to
have roughly the same proportions as a
real human being beavis and butthead by
contrast have long bulbous heads
completely out of proportion to their
tiny caricatured bodies as well as
exaggerated facial features that border
on the grotesque in bevis and butthead
do the universe when the wormhole in
1998 spits them out on a beach in 2022
the space-time anomaly of course
attracts the us government to
investigate when government agent
madison looks at a sketch drawing of
beavis and butthead he immediately says
in a grim tone whatever they are they're
definitely not human in fact madison
believing beavis and butthead are
actually part of an advanced alien
species is a running joke throughout the
film this includes the scene later on
when he hears the pair on an intercepted
cell phone call and states it's crude
but they're learning to approximate
human speech it's the meta textual
acknowledgement of beavis and butthead's
outrageous designs on top of cole's
committed delivery that sells the humor
one of the more outlandish sci-fi
concepts in beavis and butthead do the
universe are the interdimensional beings
known as smart beavis and smart butthead
the smart beavis and smart butthead
variants are styled after marvel's uatu
the watcher with pale skin bald heads
showcasing somehow even bigger foreheads
pupillous white eyes and flowing ornate
sci-fi robes smart beavis and smart
butthead have traveled to meet up with
beavis and butthead prime to warn them
that they need to enter a portal to
return back to their own timeline or the
multiverse will collapse on itself as
the prime idiots we know look on
confused smartpivos asks
did you see the cartoon spider-man movie
uh
no oh
that would have made explaining it a lot
easier with seemingly all the knowledge
in the universe at their disposal
butthead asks the most important
question he can think of did any of the
other versions ever score
no
no version of beaverton butthead has
ever scored however instead of being
dismayed beavis and butthead prime take
that as a challenge to be the first ones
all the while rather than their
trademark chuckling smart bevis and
smart butthead react with comments like
yes
the smart beavis and butthead variants
are a running gag throughout the film
with the most clever joke being the
reveal that they are still really dumb
since their plan was needlessly
complicated they are indeed the smartest
beavis and buttheads in the multiverse
that just isn't saying much
the time travel concept is used
relatively sparingly throughout beavis
and butthead do the universe despite it
being the catalyst for the whole plot
not to say there aren't funny fish out
of water scenes in which they confront
how things have changed over the years
these include jokes like discovering
what a cell phone is for the first time
as well as realizing how their childhood
home has changed but by and large that's
not the main comedic thrust of the story
however one bit that really takes
advantage of how society has shifted in
the last couple decades is a scene at a
gender studies class that beavis and
butthead accidentally crash in it the
feminist professor asks them to confront
their white privilege now to be clear
white privilege is a very real
phenomenon with devastating systemic
ramifications as for beavis and butthead
well let's just say they don't really
get it in one moment a white student
talks over a black student to explain
the concept hilariously shows the
well-intentioned lack of self-awareness
that can exist even within liberal
spaces while the film pokes fun at the
earnestness of some of the students
often oversimplified view of white
privilege it also shows a pretty
concrete example of its existence as
well
one of the most iconic bits in the
beavis bevison butthead cannon is when
beavis transforms into the great
cornholio his manic alter ego in the new
film after beavis and butthead steal a
cop car because they misunderstand the
degree to which the aforementioned white
privilege would protect them from police
naturally they're sent to prison when a
police inspection comes up a prisoner
forces beavis to hide his drugs and
beavis takes that as an invitation to
eat them this of course marks the return
of the great cornholio what puts this
scene above many of his previous
appearances are the raised stakes and
the fact that not only does cornholio
incite a prison riot he also forces the
warden to partake in prison reform while
the film isn't purely on the side of all
criminals nor prison abolition it does
seem to be on the side of humane
treatment it also subversively displays
white privilege considering the warden
decides to show beavis mercy which
probably wouldn't otherwise be the case
the main plot of beavis and butthead to
the universe is beavis and butthead's
ongoing quest to find captain serena
ryan now a governor and have sex with
her before they go to finally confront
her beavis and butthead each have their
own fantasies about what it would be
like to score it's funny to see how
hormonal he and butthead are throughout
the film but when the audience actually
sees inside his head they realize that
beavis just wants a sweet girlfriend to
cuddle with and also torture cements it
gets even funnier when he imagines her
as an avenging warrior princess in metal
bikini armor bloodily slicing up his
bullies and taking him on a ride atop
her rainbow farting pegasus steed which
also happens to have butthead's face
butthead's fantasy in which he's a
pimped out lothario wearing a tacky fur
coat and gold dollar sign jewelry
surrounded by beautiful women is less
original and comedic than beavis's but
it does have a hilarious moment where
one of the swooning women says i heard
you put your thingy in a girl's thingy
as mentioned before one of the main
conceits of beavis and butthead do the
universe is that no beavis and no butt
head in the entire multiverse has ever
had sex which given what we know about
beavis and butthead isn't much of a
surprise however that all changes at the
end of the film beavis feels he has
legitimately fallen in love with serena
though he's actually fallen in love with
siri due to being unaware of how
smartphones work he's about to confess
his true love to her when smart beavis
swoops in and offers serena a chance to
travel the cosmos as she's always
dreamed she agrees it's later revealed
that smart beavis and serena did indeed
have sex after a ceremony is held by
empress beavis and emperor butthead who
awards smart beavis an i-scored medal
meanwhile smart butthead is awarded an i
watched medal since he was hiding in a
suitcase at the foot of the bed to watch
the two do it but the best part is the
reveal of the vast number of alternate
beavises and buttheads witnessing the
ceremony seated in a futuristic space
coliseum it's a sight to behold and is
an all-around epic and hilarious way to
end the film
[Music]